I was supposed to deliver this morning
person
but who is this guy this entire fake
movie uses the office staff why not
bring in David Wallace or Hank Tate or
Bob Vance and what did Michael have to
do to convince a total stranger to allow
him to be fake shot and smeared in
ketchup I want to see that Craigslist ad
I have finally completed my movie threat
level midnight first roll those
beautiful bean commercials second what
the hell am I supposed to do with this
obviously I'm sending the office and in
the world of the office threat level
midnight is supposed to be bad so when
it succeeds is that a sin there's it a
sin removal I have an idea I'll just
send whatever I want because it's my
damn channel taking your eyes off the
active blowtorch on your hand threat
level midnight is the great lost film of
Michael Scott is it I mean is it lost
we've been working on it for a decade
sure but it's more an unfinished film
than a lost one right it's like a home
movie yeah
if Michael Scott did your home movie
you mean poor camerawork lame jokes and
completely uninteresting considering
that sums up every home movie ever made
I'm not sure your point is valid he
thought it was a comedy everything
pointed to being a comedy The Wicker Man
ladies and gentlemen except in the cold
opened earlier the title came after the
shootout in Michaels office so why did
he start it part way in although no
studio logos so as opposed to Scarn
Manor for 51 Hanover Lane Clark Summit
Pennsylvania eighteen four one two
Michael Scarn well that is an
interesting story Stan the region
Michael uses Realtors brochure as a
stand-in for the house but has full
newspaper article mock-ups done for
exposition the show is lazy with its
movie being lazy or not I please Samuel
Michael Scarn robot Butler Dwight does
not play a robot actors
when Michael said earlier that the film
had symbolism is this what he meant it's
the president
he needs you for a mission it's
goldenface we're really more Oringer
than golden but we've been to the
villain I gave up a lot of weekends
because I thought it would be good for
my daughter to see a black man as
president even in a silly home movie
what a stupid waste of time
I get it because then Obama happened
good joke but even so are we pretending
the deep impact Fifth Element and head
of state don't exist he's after the NHL
all-star game he's hidden a bomb
somewhere in a stadium in the NH oh they
call the marinas not stadiums you're
thinking of the NFL sports heads I do it
tails I don't best out of seven
hence personally I can't make heads or
tails about someone who loves movies
wouldn't understand how boring this
would be but Scott's got a Scott I guess
then I'm gonna dig up scars dead wife
and I'm gonna hump her real good I bet
when you think back on these classic
episodes of The Office
it's the necrophilia jokes that crack
you up the most huh I did not love the
dialogue or the character Joker each
year the National Hockey League accepts
one civilian amateur to play in the
all-star game there was a really easy
sin here about how stupid that idea is
and then some 42 year old Zamboni driver
in Toronto played goalie and save the
game and no I don't know what's real
anymore I mean laugh all you want but
this is basically the subway silencer
shootout and John wick - so okay bad for
what it's worth I'm so sorry I have to
do this I'm just about done with this
antihero trend am I really supposed to
root for scar and after this there's
nothing sacred
they call me Jasmine
bingo here's the thing about buying into
this homemade film on one hand they want
it to seem like an idiot did it on the
other hand do you know how hard it is to
find the right camera lighting sound and
dolly for a shot like this you can't
have it both ways the office far and
away the most expensive shot of the
movie so you pay for a lifelike dummy
head explosion and everything else in
this movie is out of pocket but you
couldn't find a way to help your Scott
Tops kids get to college remind me if
we're supposed to light the sky
that man was a wanted animal rapist I
bet when you think back on these classic
episodes at the office it's the sexual
assault bestiality jokes that crack you
up the most hell you jump to the right
and you shake to the left and you shake
okay fine this whole thing is so
over-the-top bonkers I think I just
broke if taking a sin off for a vanity
dance craze number and an action war
film is wrong I don't want to be right
yeah Michael the movie is amazing it's
like one of the best movies I've ever
seen in my life
stock film syndrome this popcorn fall is
so obvious a mechanical prop that the
bag now appears to be levitating towards
the edge of the desk and remember we
aren't even in the movie anymore also
eating popcorn over carpets I have my
book on business somehow I managed the
book title is way too good for Michael
Scott to have come up with it I am a
huge Woody Allen fan although I have
only seen ants this joke ants on for
some time I mean this joke goes on for
some ants I mean this ants goes ants
ants for some ants God ants it Michael
you have to get to that puck before a
half-time hockey doesn't have a
half-time and yes I know it's his dumb
movie again but do you really think the
same guy that loved hockey enough to
find authentic hockey gear a rink and
make it part of his block wouldn't know
that hey wait what what an infuriating
character turn Michael doesn't get to be
totally oblivious to his own
shortcomings and then immediately this
self-aware without any explanation what
the hell is this turn and where did it
come from hey we've got sports games
again the Year 2021 oh sure when it's a
simple explosion you go all grade-school
after effects but just ten seconds ago
you managed to animate a hockey puck
hitting a satellite in space our dog
would be excellent at cinema suits on TV
since about a movie in a TV show ooh
even am i right now
oh and to stop it because there are no
officials on the ice what is come over
the Charlestown chief make sure you
click that Bell icon but clicking the
little bell icon is how you make sure
you get notified every time we release a
video so click it no laughing no
comments just positive energy got a
harnessing the good energy walk out the
bad harness energy block bad Michael
Scarn well that is an interesting story
those of us who knew him best talked
about him often I swear the stuff people
Oh someone's coming alright the only man
who would care
I'm all Greg funky cat as a hippest jazz
club in town you're like jazz Bonnie how
do you keep getting back in well I'm a
peanut bar and I'm here to say your
checks will arrive on another day why
can't you just be happy for me and then
go home and talk behind my back later